well tom tuggenhead is uh with us now
hello to mr tuggenhealth thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
um you've got dominic raab in front of
you on wednesday i believe your
committee what are you going to ask him
well we're going to be looking at
exactly what happened in this evacuation
and not just looking at what happened in
the last few weeks 10 days but also
the process that led up to it a little
bit and of course
most importantly what this means going
forward look there's a possibility we
may find ourselves with the biggest
hostage crisis the uk has ever seen uh
over 3 000
uh entitled people uh were said to be in
afghanistan at the beginning of this
process i don't know how many it is now
but we'll be asking about that and uh
we'll be looking to see what that means
for getting british citizens out what
that means for getting entitled people
out and protecting those people who
quite rightly are literally in fear of
their lives now
what do you make of the americans
sharing the biometrics and other
personal details of those that had
helped the allies uh over the last 20
years with the taliban
look i i find it absolutely
extraordinary um
i mean i i barely have words to say how
stunned i am that this should be
considered by anybody uh a good idea we
all
in the very basic uh security of our
lives are
increasingly careful about our own data
security because we know that somebody
could hack our bank account or you know
post things claiming to be us on the
internet or whatever
this is just a league beyond that this
is
quite literally uh giving information to
somebody who you know is trying to kill
them
um
i mean i don't know what to say it's
completely extraordinary
i'm guessing that the brits will not
have done something like that
well that's one of the questions we're
going to be asking isn't it
i would have thought so um ben wallace
said to us this morning the defense
secretary um that the operation to uh at
the hotel at the barron hotel has now
ended but it was always going to end at
half past four this morning of course he
would say that wouldn't he because he
wouldn't want um isis k or the taliban
to think that we have brought forward
our operations because of what happened
with the bombings yesterday but we must
take him at his word what it does mean
is that in the next few hours anybody
that is still trapped outside the
airport perimeter or indeed somewhere
else around
the capital of afghanistan will not be
getting out on one of those flights you
know the area well how difficult will it
be
to maybe go over a land border
well that's what i'm literally trying to
work out at the moment and what i was
doing just before we went uh before i
came to speak to you is i've been
texting
people in the region our envoys in
various different countries um people i
know
former warlords i worked with literally
anybody i can i can think of to try and
get friends of mine out uh and into
various the neighboring countries look
there are ways in and out of afghanistan
it is after all a landlocked country and
that means that you can always walk over
the border somewhere
but the reality is it's also a very very
difficult terrain and a lot of the
neighboring states quite understandably
are looking to protect themselves from
the overspill of terrorism of the kind
that we just saw in kabul
so i'm
you know i'm i'm very very concerned for
anybody who's left behind i'm sure ben
is telling uh absolutely the truth when
he says it this was the time when it was
going to end because the reality is we
were always going to have to end before
the americans left and the americans
are leaving on the 31st because we can
get that extension so i'm sure ben is
absolutely right but it still leads as
he himself said
hundreds perhaps thousands of people
behind in what could be the biggest
hostage crisis the uk has ever dealt
with what do we do with the military
hardware that is um left behind does it
get um scorched earth policy or does it
get brought back to potentially be used
again should we return to afghanistan
what happens
well the priority will be the people uh
absolutely without question and anything
we can't take will be destroyed this is
what defeat looks like i'm afraid
i don't think somehow it's sunk into to
to some people who have been asking me
questions recently
defeat means you don't control the
situations anymore defeat means you
don't have a voice in the debate defeat
means you don't get a say
we have just been defeated we have no
influence over kabul anymore
we have no influence over the behavior
of the taliban except by asking them
nicely and luring them with aid
to help people who they're quite happy
to kill so frankly what influence that
is i'm not very convinced at the moment
so i'm afraid
you're right this is awful this is
absolutely tragic and this is why i'm
working 24 7 to try and get those people
who
stood by us in our hour of need out
because it's our moment to stand by them
we can't allow this defeat to become a
wider defeat and we need to reorganize
re-engage with allies and remember that
britain does have a voice if it wants to
use it
i was speaking to an army interpreter
this morning he said that um he he and
his family would be killed by the
taliban unless he was taken out he he
pleaded uh directly to the prime
minister but he's not at the airport
he's hiding in place and and it doesn't
look as though he's going to be on these
flights uh coming out what does defeat
look like we know what it looks like for
him what does it mean look like for the
army veterans who lost limbs or the
parents of those uh
450 or so um that died uh in afghanistan
it's exceptionally painful i mean i i
have lost nothing like
what those parents or the partners of
those who've been killed in action have
lost i've you know i lost a few years
and
and some friends who meant a lot to me
but it's not the same as losing your
life partner your father your son your
daughter
it's not the same and and i'm sure it's
exceptionally painful
for all those people
and that's why we need to remember what
they fought for
and why what they fought for matters
they fought for each other first of all
they fought for the men and women on
either side of them and their courage
saved lives
they also fought for the people of
afghanistan
and their courage saw girls educated saw
infant mortality drop
saw opportunities grow saw people
transform and it saw the taliban yes
come back but come back to a very
different afghanistan
and finally they fought for the values
of the british people and they expressed
them
literally to the end
in an act of supreme courage that
frankly few of us could match and for
that we should all be eternally grateful
because we're seeing that same courage
reflected
by the soldiers in kabul today we saw it
reflected in the u.s marines who were
killed yesterday
they died
keeping their friends safe they died on
guard
making sure that the enemies of their
friends the enemies of their people
would not pass
now that is courage and that is what
these people this is what our veterans
brought to afghanistan and bring to our
country so
let's not say that they were defeated
they weren't it's a political decision
it's a decision very unwisely made in
the white house
and it's one that we will all pay for
but it is not a military defeat before i
let you go um coming up um immediately
after you i'm going to be speaking to a
former interpreter
who worked for the brits whose
application has been refused what would
you say to him either
as a former soldier or as a politician
i i have nothing to say as a former
soldier as a politician but as a person
all i can say is my heart goes out to
you
those who stood up for us
deserve the protection
that they are entitled to expect because
we promised it you know this isn't a
deal
some people have invented just now this
isn't some sort of you know after the
fact offer
we made this deal we made this promise
and the whole point about britain's
strength in the world is that our word
is our bond when we say something we
mean it that's what has built up
britain's strength over 200 300 years
when we've made threats we've carried
them out when we've made promises we've
stood by them when we've made allies
we've been there for them
we better do we keep doing that again
otherwise we're going to seriously
undermine our position okay tom tugan
huh thank you very much indeed for
joining us